رحله نحو مستقبل جديد وساحه للمنافسه على
بناء منصه عالميه واحده للمواهب هذه
الرحله ستنطلق من مدينه جده ضمن النسخه
الثانيه من المؤتمر العالمي للموهبه
والابداع 20 22 مجتمع عالمي مبتكر هو
الهدف الذي يجتمع لتحقيق قرابه 100 مشارك
من المبتكرين والموهوبين ورواد اعمال من
30 دوله وخلال المؤتمر سيقدم المشاركون
حلولا ابداعيه لتحديات التي يواجهها
العالم لتحسين حياه البشر في كل مكان
وكذلك جلسات حواريه وعروضها للمواهب
بالاضافه لفعاليه ايضيه سيشارك فيها ايضا
مليمونه ورؤسات تنفيذيون ورياديون في
قطاعات مختلفه على كل حال سنحاول مع لميس
الاجابه على سؤال اساسي كيف تعرف ان ابنك
موهوب او بنتك موهوبه
اذا بالفعل كيف تعرف ان طفلك موهوب يبدا
ذلك بملاحظه بعض المفارقات التي تظهر
عليهم منذ سنوات الاولى ومن اهم السمات
السلوكيه التي رسمتها مؤسسه موهبه ملاحظه
ان الطفل يعقد مقارنه لاكتشاف العلاقات
بين الاشياء ويطرح الكثير من الاسئله
الجديده بالاهتمام
وعرض تشكيلات حسب ما يتاح له واعطاء بدائل
متعدده لمشكله واحده وقد يقدم اجابات
الاسئله بشكل اكبر من عمر الزمني ويربط
النتائج بالاسباب الطفل الموهوب ايضا يجرب
الاشياء الجديده ولديه قدره على ادراك
المساحات والاحجام والمسافات ويستطيع ايضا
ان يتعامل مع الارقام والرموز الرياضيه
بسهوله ويستوعب المبادئ والقواعد الرياضيه
ليسر كما انه يتمتع بخيال واسع ولديه ثقه
بنفسه وبارائه
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى جده الدكتور نزيه العثماني نائب
الامين العام لمؤسسه موهبه ورئيس اللجنه
التنفيذيه للمؤتمر العالمي الثاني للموهبه
والابداع مرحبا بكم معنا واهلا بكم في
صباح العربيه دكتور نزيه دكتور نزيه تجربه
المؤتمر الاول كانت مجرد محطه انطلاق
عليها اليوم ما الذي سيثمر هذا العام
النسخه الاولى من المؤتمر العالمي للموهبه
الابداع جمعت الجهات التي ترعى الموهوبين
من امريكا اوروبا شرق اسيا لانتناقش في
افضل الوسائل المرتبطه برعايه الموهوبين
ااه فاحد توصياتها كانت بناء منصه عالميه
تكون حاضنه للموهوبين من كل انحاء العالم
عبر القارات في هذه النسخه الثانيه نقول
موهبه قول فعل وتعزيز للرياضه السعوديه في
رعايه الموهوبين على مستوى العالم جمعنا
100 موهوب من 30 دوله تم اختيارهم بعنايه
من افضل 30 جامعه على مستوى العالم من
الذين حققوا انجازات عالميه في مجالات
الفيزياء والكيمياء والاحياء والرياضيات
والعلوم وسيتمعون سويا لبناء هذه المنصه
التي ستكون حاضنه لهم في المستقبل
يا دكتور نزيه ما هي مشاكل العالم
المستقبليه التي تتطلب توظيف مواهب
ومبتكرين لخدمه البشريه
العالم اصبح قريه واحده العالم اصبح
المشاكل البيئه مشاكل الطاقه ومشاكل الفقر
ومشاكل الغذاء مشاكل المياه لم تعد مشكله
اقليم معين او دوله معين للوحده فهي مشكله
عالميه تتطلب تكاتف الجهود عبر الحدود
للتعامل معها بشكل همم بشكل متكامل يخدم
كل البشريه وكل الانسانيه وهذا ما نطرح له
من خلال المنصه المنصه ستمكن الشركات
الكبرى هناك ارامكو سابك نيوم شركات صينيه
شركات امريكيه كاكس كاوست موجودين يرغون
في لديهم تحديات عالميه ويرغبون بعقول
متميزه تقوم بتقديم الحلول الاتكاريه وهذه
المنصه ستربط بين هذه العقود وبين الجهات
الرائده
للخروج ب- همم فرق عمل المتميزه عبر
الحدود وعبر القارات همم تقدم حلول مبتكره
تستفيد منها هذه الجهات
طيب الدكتور نزيه موهبه نجحت في اكتشاف
ورعايه مواهب عده من كلا الجنسيين ما هي
المواهب التي تتمتع بها النساء نوعا ما
اكثر من الرجال فيها وافقه معاناتكم
ان استجابه النساء لفرص الرعايه وفرص
الدخول في برامج متقدمه في مجالات العلوم
الاستجابه للنساء اكثر من الاولاد النسب
في عدد المكتشفين المتشابهه 48 52 91 51
49 لكن عندما نعلن عن برنامج متميز فيه
التزام وانضباط في مجال علمي وهندسي او
طبي او صحي نجد ان دخول البنات لهذه
البرامج اكثر بالنسبه اكثر من الاولاد
حقيقي
همم وقبل ان نصل الى موهبه والى هذه
المؤسسات اليوم منذ اي عمر ومنذ الصغر
علينا ان نكتشف ونتبارك بان طفلنا موهوبا
مثلا
موهبه تقدم باستعراق معوز بشراكه مع وزاره
التعليم البرنامج الوطني للكشف عن
الموهوبين او تقدم ايضا بشراكم على ليلكسو
بمسابقه الموهوبون العرب التي يشارك فيها
طلاب موهوبون من العالم العربي حاليا هناك
16 دوله رشحت طلاب وطالبات وتم تقديم
اختبار مقياس موهبه لهم وستعل ان النتائج
الاسبوع الماضي همم نقطه مهمه على الطالب
الموهوب انه كثيرا ما يصنف الموهوبون
بانهم مشاغون بانهم مشاكسون همم ليس
بالضروره ان يكون الطالب متفوق علميا
ليكون موهوبا طالب الموهوب يفهم الدروس
بشكل سريع فيهم الدرس في اول خمس دقائق
فتصبح الحصه باقي الحصه بالنسبه له ملالا
فيبدا يتصرف
ويشغل نفسه باشياء اخرى لو المعلم لم يكن
واعيا بانه مكتشف وانه موهوب
سيستمت ستكون هناك مشكله لهذا الطالب
فالاكتشاف هو اهم رحله في عمليه رعايه
الموهبه وليس بالضروره ان يكون الطالب
تفوق علميا ليكون اا مفكرا بطريقه مختلفه
مفكرا باسلوب مختلف وهذا الذي نبحث عنه
نبحث عن الذين يفكرون بطلاقه يفك ينظرون
للامور بطريقه مختلفه يقدمون حلولا اا غير
تقليديه وغير همم
جديده مختلفه عما نتعود من سماعه من الطلب
الاخرين
صفات الموهوب زميلتنا اشواق المنتجه في
البرنامج اعتبرت هذه الصفات تمثلها
فبالتالي انا اعرض ان تتبنوها وترعونها في
مؤسستكم شكرا جزيلا
اهلا اهلا وسهلا ومرحبا بتشرف
شكرا لك